hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new edition of
collider connected with one of my
absolute
favorites and he knows it it's william
zapka
from cobra kai karate kid as well and a
whole bunch of other things that we're
going to get to talk about today
how are you doing hey perry and you are
one of my favorites and you know it too
i know you know it
i i love you and the cobra kai team so
so much and you know i could talk about
cobra kai all day long but the cool
thing about collider connected
is we get to talk about a little bit of
everything and you have a whole bunch of
accomplishments that i think
people need to know about more than they
do as much as we need to celebrate cobra
kai more
we have to hit on those as well and i'm
going right back to the very beginning
with this conversation
what is the very first thing that
sparked the urge to become an actor was
it seeing a specific
movie a performance maybe your parents
working in the industry
you name it great question well i grew
up in the industry
my dad was the associate director of the
tonight show he was a staff director at
nbc he was an emmy nominee
winning director of the soap opera when
i was five years old i was on a train
with him from long island to new york
city nbc and i was
you know on all the sets walking through
you know opening doors that went to
nowhere so
seeing the facades and seeing the makeup
getting put on and
all that it was a very young age was
impressed upon me um
and my father directed a documentary the
first thing i ever did i was five years
old also in my backyard and he directed
a documentary based on a song he wrote
about five young kids uh that grew up
together and went off to vietnam and it
starts off in this kind of
film style narrative and then it turns
into documentary footage
and i was the young kid in the backyard
with my friends remembering my dad on
the top of the roof of the camera
so from the time i can remember um i've
been
seeing sets and on all that and then
moved to move to california when i was a
kid
my dad worked at a love boat and worked
with clint eastwood but it was always a
hobby it wasn't something i i
the the light didn't go off until
maybe maybe 14 15
when i thought you know i would watch
like the bad news bears movie or
and see kid actors um i'm the littlest
angel i think was a movie i saw and
just i don't know i always thought that
was so cool i remember being on the set
of um
land of the lost the original land of
the lost and saw the kid that played
chaka this kid in this little ape suit
and took his took the ape suit mask off
and he looked like me and i remember
asking
do we have enough money to pay to be on
television
they said well no they you get paid to
do that so for me it was something that
was
so cool and so fun to do that i was like
all right
sign me up are you watching the cnn
documentary series about late night tv i
was just watching
the cars and stuff and it's like it's
incredible my folks met on that show
ed mcmahon gave my parents a wedding
gift um my dad was actually on the
carson show
as a guest because he was also a
composer and wrote a lot of movie themes
so he got to
conduct the orchestra google that go
google stan's after johnny carson you
see my dad on the carson show
and he's even talking about my folks
it's it's great but no i'm not i haven't
seen that i haven't seen that series yet
but i'm gonna
definitely check it out that's the first
thing that i'm gonna google when we hang
up
yeah that's cool are you are you a long
island kid i am a long island kid
i might be recording from long island
right now i am also a long island kid
on long island nassau county from port
washington ah
that's right nearby washington's great
area yeah and i love it that my
childhood in new york was like
amazing like the first it's almost a
whole other life tons of great friends
on the block there we lived
at the end of a bay between two ponds um
some of the kids there are still
friends of mine you know the kids i grew
up with um
yeah love new york love long island i
couldn't agree more so
you said you made the decision that you
want to pursue acting as a career and
when that happened
what did your parents say i mean i'm
assuming they were having a very
positive experience in the industry and
they encouraged you or was there any
hesitation there
no my parents have always been
most supportive parents whatever i chose
to do um it was also too like i
also wanted to be a filmmaker so when i
graduated high school i didn't go to
acting school to become an actor i
actually went to film school
to become a filmmaker and acting was
like kind of my
side thing like i played music as well
but i wasn't i wasn't trying to be in a
band it was
so um so they're very supportive my dad
having dealt with
many different types of actors just to
just you know keep your head on your
shoulders keep your feet on the ground
stay true to yourself um keep your
friends
um and uh you know so i had i had some
good guidance on that
and but um they were fully supportive of
that
um and soon after i i kind of decided to
do that
i was in college cal state northridge
going to film school and i got cast in
karate kid
and um and the rest is history sort of
i do always like asking about going to
film school specifically because
it's not a mandatory thing you could do
one or the other and it's whatever feels
right to you but you know you brought up
film school i know you started but then
you didn't finish and i assume that has
something to do with getting the karate
kid roll what was it like
making that decision especially because
it it seems like
wanting to be behind the camera has
always been important to you what i
realized was i was getting because i
after karate kid then it was
back to school and just one of the guys
in european vacation and the equalizer
my acting career
kept going so i had to go on that ride
but i was also realizing
i was learning way more than i could
ever in school actually doing it
and and seeing the cameras and seeing
the dps and learning what a grip is and
what a gaffer is and
how to hit your mark and how the actors
work i mean my film school
uh had was was on the job training in
acting and um
and i'd always ask the dps you know
what's that what's that
what kind of film is that and what
what's film stock and what's a lens and
you know it's a prime what's a you know
what's a zoom with
all those things fascinated by all that
so it was film school for me and i
learned so much from that
um so for me to go back to to college to
do what i was already doing
you know it didn't seem to make sense
but then i did go back and took some
writing classes at ucla and i went to
music school and graduated guitar
i did not know that i'm learning so much
about you to touch on karate kids
specifically now do you remember what
you had to
audition with to get that role yeah it
was a scene that was cut
out of the film funny enough um i think
it's out there somewhere
in the rehearsal form it's a scene where
i confront daniel at school
right before the tournament i hand him a
death certificate he's at a water
fountain
and uh he says what's this so you gotta
get your mommy to sign that so you could
be in the tournament with the big boys
and then he says i thought it was
supposed to be no contact and then i say
yeah well accidents happen
and then i turn and walk away he goes
hey you think he might be wrong and i
say
who because your sense that you think he
might be wrong and then my line is
watch your mouth [ __ ] so that was my
scene and i walked up i grabbed john
allison
said watch your math [ __ ] i had a
headband on in my audition i remember
walking to the
i exited the room in this dramatic you
know fashion and then
came back in took my headband off and
sat down in front of john and said i'm
sorry that was johnny that wasn't billy
and
he got very like so how old are you and
you know you're a little bigger than our
karate kid and i said yeah well you know
bruce lee was smaller than cream abdul
jabar but he beat him he goes yeah
that's true that's true
so that was the scene and then i read it
with ralph uh that was the only scene
that i auditioned for
i read with ralph he read with a number
of guys um
and they brought me to a room the next
audition was to basically stretch me out
and see how limber i was and if they
could work with me physically
and uh you know ten hours later i got
the call
oh my that's a really short process
yeah well over a period a month and a
half okay okay yeah this is like waiting
and they
reading through people and yeah it was a
long burn i wasn't sure it was going to
happen
just because i'm curious now was the
headband thing in the character
description
when you first got you know your
original sides or is that something that
you brought to the audition
oh something i brought to it i wore my
headband i came right from the gym i
think in a tank top and a headband
and uh felt you know felt tough i didn't
hey listen at that time i didn't know
karate i didn't know how to ride a
motorcycle
last thing i did was a milk commercial
so i figured well i better do something
that looks sort of tough
so i feel i feel like that's you
instantly connecting to the character
without knowing it because his
headband's such an iconic
part of the character it's so true yeah
yeah became that and then they then they
said okay we love the headband idea then
they got the long black one and
it was just a basic bandana i think on
my audition
all right let's talk a little bit about
working with ralph as a scene partner so
what's what's one thing that hasn't
changed about him something that he did
exactly the same way when you were
making karate kid and then
on the other hand what's something about
when you hit the set with him for
cobra kai that made you go huh like even
after all these years i didn't know you
were capable of that
well our chemistry was it was kind of
instant john appleton
cast the entire film so well and all
those
all these relationships were my my
relationship with ralph on the karate
kid was
you know training every single day for
this final fight so we had to trust each
other we got
we learned together we were very much in
sync then he'd go off and do his
his dna with miyagi stuff and then when
we were film i would i was basically
attacking him
you know until the end and then we had
to do that so we we had an ins we had a
we built a long
relationship of trust and it's
instinctive so when we go back and we
we step into the dojo and in the first
season of cobra kai
and he walks into the dojo is a
familiarity
um it's an instant chemistry that's not
spoken that's not
it's effortless um and then we uh when
we get into our physical
stuff our physical fighting we're on the
fast track because we in a sense already
can anticipate by just looking at each
other's eyes what's coming next so
um that's something that's built in um
so it's a new experience working with
them now because we're
you know we're becoming partners kind of
seeing eye to eye and
bat you know bumping heads there's a lot
of different levels and
complexities in the in the characters
and in the relationship so
it's it's much broader and much much
more
full to play those those moments but
it's it's uh it's very familiar i guess
i could say you know
easy in the sense of we trust each other
with the wheel
all right now jumping into what happened
after the release of
the karate kid is that a situation where
kind of
blows the doors wide open to many many
new
possibilities and are you in a situation
where
yeah i know how this industry behaves
you do one thing really well and they
want to keep giving you more of that
thing and
not even recognizing the fact that you
might be possible of everything else
yeah those were the easy ones i think
you know and
if i could do it again i may make
different choices um
but for me it was just i just you know
first of all no one saw the karate kid
turning into
classic you know at that moment it was
just a couple years out maybe you're out
and parts are coming my way
i love acting um so the roles came in um
and but i auditioned for a lot of things
you know
i mean i met oliver stone for platoon
and you know i mean
so i've i've been i had those
opportunities and i and i had those
auditions and stuff but
i think sure the business you know which
they like to to use what's working and
what's familiar but uh yeah but uh
i have no regrets i i i i'm proud of all
of it
i do like talking often about bumps in
the road and either how
you overcame them or like an important
lesson that became very valuable from
something that maybe didn't pan out so
bringing up some auditions
after that that maybe didn't go your way
is there any particular audition
experience that is
you know stuck with you even though you
didn't go on to do that movie or show
no i mean all of them each each audition
has a lesson in it
every time you get her don't get
something you walk away from it
um you know i got close on some some
very
cool movies you know one of them was
days of thunder it was carrie always
chris
chris penn and myself for the for the
driver towards the end
and um you know going through that that
that door you know just being in the mix
of those guys me and being considered
for that was was incredible
you know um so you walk away from that
and you get the part but you feel like
hey
they're looking at me in that light
that's a that's a cool thing you know
that's a positive thing going into one
you did get now
the equalizer your first multi-episode
run
on a tv show there is there anything you
experienced
working on that show or maybe even
something that you observe
edward woodward doing as a lead that you
find coming in handy now
leading cobra kai that was my acting
school
working with him he was i mean one of
the greatest actors of all time i mean
he's just such a thespian and all the
actors robert mitchum was on that
shirley knight great actress played my
wife and my wife my mom
um but just working with all of them
um edward i'll never forget the first
scene that we did together it was in a
hallway at this
at the school the music school and i was
going doing my scene with
with him and um you know he he said to
me as i walked
where he says you are a very good actor
you know i was like
wow thank you because no it starts in
here and it comes out here
and i thought wow what a boost now was i
or not i don't know but
it sure gave me a lot of confidence
that's kind of made me feel
you know it's so i think you learned you
know how generous he was how giving he
was and um
you know and then what a what a
professional and and
he knew everything he knew you know he
knew was fixing a light over there in
the middle of his lines he was just so
in tune with the whole
machine which i think came from a lot of
experience and i do have that now
because i've been behind the camera
i know i would have directed i've edited
um you know written i've produced so i
know
i know the whole machine you know and um
and he did
at that time and i was young actor so i
he was very in tune with everything
and um yeah so i learned so much from
him just watching him just working with
him his level his intensity
he challenged me a lot that was filmed
that was acting school for me
working on that show and away from the
team the teen kind of movies
having spoken to so many of the young
ensemble in cobra kai i feel like you
and ralph are definitely bringing a
similar sense of generosity to them they
always speak so highly of you guys and i
love hearing about it
yeah i think the next thing on my list
kind of brought me to the hot tub time
machine
area and it was making me wonder because
i'm surprised i've never even asked you
this before
it's how did you first meet john josh
and hayden and did meeting josh have
anything to do with
your work in hot tub time machine
yeah so uh a hot tub time machine
i was it was an offer they wrote josh
shield wrote this character
um and they reached out to me and and
basically went in and
they had already shot the movie they did
some test screenings and there was
apparently a dip somewhere in the middle
and they wanted to bump something up
so they wrote a part and they had me in
mind and uh so i met josh that way i
walked into a room and he literally
created this
character for me and uh for the movie
and uh
and then uh hayden and john horowitz
came to visit because they were such
good friends
um and they had reached out to me hayden
and john reached out to me previous to
that
uh something about a harold and kumar
sequel didn't pan out
but i knew who they were and uh we kind
of instantly clicked all of us it was
kind of cool
and i always thought somewhere in the
back of my mind i always had this
feeling about those guys i always
thought you know one day we're gonna all
all of us do something together um many
times so when they emailed me out of the
blue
saying we have an idea for a project it
felt like oh yeah
here's that thing i've been feeling yeah
well it must be the most
uh incredible boost in confidence that
you're you're called
in to essentially fix a lull in a movie
they must have had that sounds wrong
no it was the scene you know i mean it
could anybody could have done it you
know
a mustache on it it was the scene but
they thought who could play this
character right you know
that was so fun i loved playing that guy
you know he had a name he had a first
name rick his name was rick
and i remember being on set and uh steve
pink who directed it and josh they're
like we're trying to find
his last name it just came out his
name's not rick it's ricky and his last
name's steelman it's ricky steeleman
the mustache there's just something so
funny about that name all right we got
to touch on how i met your mother
and i want to know how exactly that
came up and what your reaction was when
you found out what their take on
karate kid was because they were
essentially teeing up cobra kai
yeah in many ways um well first of all
for to get the phone call uh to be uh to
do a guest spot on how i met your mother
just by itself was was thrilling i'm
just like wow
and then then they said we're gonna send
you the script so the script comes in
and it's uh there's a clown and there's
ralph macchio
and there's a clown and there's a clown
in the clown and then you know the paint
the last pages and the clown takes his
makeup off and it's me
you know so i have no words the whole
the whole thing until the very last
there's this little speech there
at the end i said well that's a safe way
to bring me on television just put me to
clown suit and zip my mouth up
um but uh so that was so much fun i mean
what a great i can't say enough about
about that set
that crew and all those actors and how
welcoming they made us feel and um
you know what it what a shot they gave
me just to to do that um
and it turned out great so there yeah i
i knew about the show and i knew about
barney stinson's
you know take on who johnny lawrence was
and he was a real good guy which was
kind of like a
you know tick in his own character
because he saw things so skewed which
made him so endearing
um so the fact it made sense that he
would think johnny was the hero like
darth vader was the hero of star wars
you know um so it's comedy bit um and
then uh and after that show
after it was just supposed to be that
one-off i think and then
uh then i got a call saying um you know
they want to have you back
and they're gonna bring you into season
nine and and give you a
you know a few episodes a bunch of
episodes or whatever and give you an arc
and that was that was that was just
amazing you know
they wrote there they're so strange to
sit at a table with you know
neil patrick harris and kobe and jason
um
siegel and see all their character names
all around the table and the table reads
you know as ted mosby and barney stinson
and then there's a card there and it
says billy zabka
you know billy zapka has himself it was
like how am i how did i break this wall
how am i on the show
i was i think i pinched myself a lot
under the table going this is incredible
and they were just such great actors and
such since they were so inspiring and
neil men
he would be getting ready to do the tony
awards host to tony awards and doing two
other things while he's carrying the
show
and uh he's just a machine and just so
gracious
so gracious and so um it's just
encouraging and um
i'm just thankful pam fryman the
director of that was just
the best i love her so if you're
watching this pam thank you again
all right i don't want to jump into
cobra kai without touching on most and i
know in one of our last conversations we
spoke about it a little bit so i'll just
remind everyone that
most is an academy award nominated short
film that you both co-wrote
and produced and it's well worth seeking
out and you admitted it so i could say
this now it's online you google it you
can find it
right so i know when we last spoke you
described it as
a labor of love and clearly it went on
to be a great success so how does an
experience like that
change your goals for yourself what
would you say is the biggest difference
between
what you were drawn to before the most
experience
and then after well
i i was doing a lot of indie films uh in
in eastern europe and bulgaria and doing
a lot of you know i'd read these scripts
and they look like hey
they do this right this could be good
and a lot of corners are cutting some of
these lower budget things and i was
getting a little like creatively
unsatisfied say at least um and wanted
to make something that had some meaning
and some depth
it was on the on the heels of 9 11 two
weeks after 9 11
um and um the story jumped on me and my
partner at the time were like let's go
and
tell this story um but but it wasn't a
career thing
it wasn't like oh that i want to go and
you know it wasn't about the academy
awards it was about doing something
excellent and we did something out of
the box we did something in eastern
europe with a czech cast
we shot it in poland it didn't make
sense on paper i mean it's a big budget
for this little 33 minute film
that we put two years into we battled
floods we battled negative 11 to
11 degrees on a on a polish drawbridge
and
um it was really insurance battle to
have to come back because our
bridge broke and then we then when we
were done we cut it together and brought
it through the festival circuit and um
and it just was you know started the
sundance and then it just picked up
traction
and people were responding to it um and
then next thing we're walking the red
carpet the academy awards you know like
three years later
and um you know as a filmmaker
difference of like making a movie as an
actor
or a show as an actor you know and then
you you walk away and six months later
eight months later you see a premiere of
it
but when you're doing everything and
you're orchestrating the whole thing
you know every painful step of a way to
get to where you are you know you know
where you
every moment of that journey so to to be
walking into
to be at the oscars which is such an
honor um and it was just a great
platform for the film you know and i
stayed behind it i didn't put myself out
in front of it i didn't do publicity
about it and say look at me here
it wasn't about that it was really so
much about the film that i didn't want
anybody even though i had anything to do
with it
but it was so great to be there and then
from that it was
it was very um encouraging that all the
all that i've learned over the years
and all my all my film school that i've
been doing on sets and from the shows
and from all these things everything i
set out to do back in college um
happened and and was you know
got a nomination for them for the
highest honor
in in in in what i want to do so that
was uh if anything just uh
you know good feeling you know i didn't
think of it in a strategic thing like oh
now i'm gonna go and
do that you know i know i have that in
my belly i have that in my
that my in my box and i'll i'll do
something else again
when the right timing is i'll get behind
the camera and uh
do something that uh comes from inside
me there's only one follow-up question
to that
have you revisited the possibility of
directing an episode of cobra kai
i've thought about it i thought about it
kicked around talk to the guys about
that and
maybe that's in the cards you know um i
think at this point we've been along
for now four seasons the rhythm's there
all the actors know each other we trust
each other the machine's
working i mean we have an amazing crew
amazing crew
and cast and you know it's great to this
thing happens so fast we throw these
these episodes together pretty quick an
incredible schedule some of the hours
are
12 14 hours sometimes 16 hour days and
it takes all of us at the same time to
to do that so if i was gonna direct it
would
take a lot of extra time so the moment
comes the right episode comes
uh with all my heart i would i would uh
i would love to do that
i see that so i see that in the cards
i'm not angling for that but
when it's when it's right no i agree
when the time is right but i might be
rooting for that to happen
the time is right yeah i've got my hands
full playing this guy and
uh you know that's uh that's where my
heart's at with the show right now
all right let's jump into some specifics
here maybe let's go for
the fights between johnny and cree so i
was wondering if you could kind of
compare and contrast the fight in
the beginning of season two to where we
see them
in that fight at the end of season three
and
maybe from a fight style perspective and
keep in mind i have limited knowledge
here but it does kind of feel like
there's more precision
and more intensity to the way that
johnny is fighting him in
season three so if that is the case
maybe what kind of discussions did you
guys have to make sure that the audience
doesn't just see a fight but also sees
character growth within that fight
the first fight is an emotional fight
the first fight is he hasn't seen this
guy thought he was dead
um this is the guy that steered him off
track and there's a lot of
um a lot of anger a lot of pain in that
first fight it was a very emotional
fight which can allow for it to be a
little sloppier
um not a perfect uh you know technical
martial art fight
the third one in season three is a is a
kind of a
um uh righteous anger
kind of it's uh you know when he took
away the dojo at the end of season two
and it became chris's dojo that moment
when he
you know he's been betrayed again
johnny's been betrayed he let chris into
his life into his heart he cared for him
and gave him a chance and now all of a
sudden he just
stabbed him in the back um that was the
lowest point besides miguel getting
injured
right and then um so at the end of
you know in season three when uh when
it's gone too far
and um he's injured miguel again and
um johnny's going back so there's a lot
of
intention in the fighting style um and
in my performance of it too
it's it's a little so it's kind of all
together but it's not a conscious
discussion like you know hey the first
one's gonna be a little more
gorilla kind of more straight slop and
this one's going to be a little more
uh you know a target so um it was
mostly about the emotion of it and i
think that translates through
the fighting style and the precision and
intensity and the intention of each move
um so it was very i love that i love
kicking the door down it felt good
it felt good because it felt as good as
it did bad when he when he was saying
you know
i started cobra kai you know it's mine
you know and johnny has to leave this
tail between his legs
experiment that he tried and he's trying
to help all these kids and
you know and now boom you know this guy
pulls it out from under him on top of
miguel getting injured i mean that's a
super low point
so it was a high point for him to come
back in and just get his power back
um especially where he was at the
beginning of the season which was
completely
um licking his wounds and feeling
responsible for this whole train wreck
and so at the end of it uh he
and that's on the also on the heels of
ali setting him free to go find his true
love
so he's he's rising up again and that's
a
that all played in the fight revisiting
all this gets me so pumped all over
again
specific specific beat now within that
uh
the season three fight between johnny
and crease
if robbie hadn't yelled at johnny to
stop do you think that
johnny still would have dropped the psy
or would he have used it
he would have probably used it but he
would have probably been non-lethal
i think at that moment he was out of
control but i don't know
um i knew he was going to stop me so
that was a good thing
you know i think uh you know sometimes
you're getting in a fight and someone's
you know you're puffed up to fight
someone and they're like somebody breaks
it up and you're like yeah
you're lucky that that guy just broke it
up you know but you really relieved
inside
so i don't know at the moment of that
you know i i think not i think he would
have i don't think he would have used i
think johnny's cape honestly i don't
think johnny's capable of that
i think that he may have um trapped him
he may have pinned him he may have shown
him that he won
um he may have threatened him um
dominated him with a bit he wouldn't
have injured him on that there's too
many lessons learned along the way that
if like if robbie hadn't been the first
thing to stop him
something else that he learned in his
own mind i think would have
all right i have to let you go soon i
can't believe we're almost out of time
i have to ask you about season four and
i know that the last time
i asked you for season three details
before it came out you couldn't give
much of a tease i know that's gonna be
the case here so instead
i'll approach a season four question the
same way you answered the season three
question here
how does johnny feel at the end of
season three
where where exactly is his head at in
that last moment
it's a complicated feeling for one you
know
he has a daniel just pretty much saved
them
you know to chris was just about to
choke him out um
so i think he's purged at that moment
it's a
there's an emptiness of it of it but as
a he's um
empowered with daniel and it's there's a
good feeling of bearing the hatchet so
at the end of that
but there's also um there's an intensity
they have a common
foe increase now um so the feeling of
that was
um let's was a relief in a sense of
um i have a partner and uh we have the
same
we have the same goal here um but we
have a lot of work to do
and there's still a lot of history
between us and we're both different
and we you know it's like we want this
to work
and um here we go you did it well again
you played you played you played by the
rules but you gave me a little something
to think about
yeah yeah there's a there's a lot to
clean up here with these kids all coming
together and now we have to march on
into uh
into the battle and you know these are
two complex characters
um but who are so similar but so
different
has anything felt different filming
season four
now that you are fully under the netflix
umbrella both
production wise but also maybe just
having a different vibe on set
because your fan base just grew
exponentially it was
already a very powerful group of people
but
the amount of discussion has just gone
from like one level to through the
stratosphere and
even from a fan perspective it has been
so exciting
to see that and to feel that so i can't
even imagine how it changed the vibe on
set
yeah it's just encouraging you know it's
like you know you
you have a good show and and you know
you have a matinee and
the curtains close and people are
applauding and they like it um and you
know you got the evening show coming now
and you got to go out and you know
you know there's a sense of okay it's
working they like it and
a new kind of energy um of um
you know it feels good feels good when
it's
when it's working than that but as an
actor and my job is
is to you know stay in the focus stay in
the in the micro of it you can't
you can't be swayed by that you can't be
looking at that you know it's like
you know if you're a baseball player and
you're up a bat you know you can't
you can't look to the left and see who's
in the it was in the stands you got to
keep your eye on the ball
so we're all doing that keeping our
heads tucked the writers are doing their
thing
and we're putting our hearts on our
sleeves and beating our arms up and
i'm shooting big and wide and the
stories are deep
and wide and uh i think we're gonna
deliver a great season four
but it's been it's awesome it's awesome
it's great i'm very happy to i mean why
not you know
why do this if people are gonna like it
i'm so excited for you guys keep your
eye on the ball when you're on set but i
hope you guys are all
like celebrating just recognizing the
fact that you're delivering great work
and it's making so many people out there
just so incredibly happy myself included
billy thank you so much for hanging out
with us on the channel again you're
always
such a treat and pleasure to talk to you
thank you so much
all right to everyone out there you know
what to do go over to
netflix and i mean even if you've
already watched it just re-binge it
re-binge it share your favorite scenes
in the comments section below tell us
how much you love the show
thanks for watching this edition of
collider connected we'll see you soon
with more of them